now first here at five o'clock we have
new autopsy results just released on the
driver who authorities say caused that
deadly six-car crash in north las vegas
earlier this year thanks for joining us
here at five i'm denise valdis and i'm
brian loftis those autopsy reports
showing that 59 year old gary robinson
had a significant amount of cocaine in
his system christian casares joining us
now with what else the reports reveal
christian well denise and brian the
reports were they were released today as
you mentioned tess found not only
cocaine but pcp and alcohol in
robinson's system
it's been weeks since that horrific
deadly weekend crash in north las vegas
but now new details about the driver who
allegedly caused it according to the
clark county coroner gary dean
robinson's autopsy shows the 59-year-old
died of blunt force injuries but had a
large amount of cocaine among other
illegal substances in his body at the
time of the crash urine and blood tests
found cocaine pcp and alcohol in
robinson's system autopsy and toxicology
reports said
on january 29 the north las vegas
resident was driving a dodge challenger
police say he ran a red light driving
more than 100 miles per hour at commerce
street and cheyenne avenue both robinson
and his female passenger 46-year-old
tanaga miller died people had pay
attention that crash also killed seven
members of the zacarias family that were
traveling inside this toyota minivan
including four children two stepsons and
a brother their parents speechless but
grateful for the outpour of community
support helping raise a hundred thousand
dollars through a gofundme account
well the 8 news now i-team also learning
robinson pled guilty for speeding up to
10 miles per hour over the speed limit
in early december of last year where
according to court records he paid a 150
dollar fine christian casa is live local
now